ومسيحي ماذا عن
خصومك ، سواء كانوا من الصين أو
أه منافسين أه على الأقل أنت تعرف من حيث
السياسة الخارجية لنا
أه مثل فلاديمير بوتين
جيدًا يمكنك أن تتخيل خصومًا مثل
منافسي روسيا مثل الصين
، لقد كانوا سعداء للغاية بصراحة في
الأيام اللامتناهية من  يحسبون أن الأمر استغرق
لأن ما يحلو لهم هو أن يروا
المؤسسات الأمريكية والمؤسسات الغربية
تقلل من شأنها وأن تتدهور هذا
ما
يحلو لهم وكانوا يعرفون أنهم
تمكنوا من الظهور على أجهزة التلفزيون الخاصة بهم
على ما بدا أنه رئيس مزعج
أم تشويه سمعة  العملية في الولايات المتحدة التي
ترفض قبول العد في
محاولة لإيقاف العد ، لقد كانوا جميعًا يقولون
إنها ديمقراطية تعلمون أنها
أمريكا
ما هذا ، لذا من دواعي
ارتياح الجميع أن يرى هذا العدد
أه يصل أخيرًا إلى النهاية.
بقدر ما
تم تسمية الرئيس المنتخب وأه
أمريكا بشكل
أساسي تقدم الآن درسًا حيًا
في
الديمقراطية وأنا  أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس ، الكثير من
القادة ، الكثير من الناس حول العالم
حريصون جدًا على أن تستعيد الولايات المتحدة
نوع واجبها
الأخلاقي القيم
التي طالما سعت دائمًا
إلى تعزيزها
وتم الاعتماد عليها
دائمًا وأعتقد  هذا أمر مهم حقًا ،
أعني أنك تعرف بشكل مثير للاهتمام أن
رئيس الوزراء الصيني
قال الأسبوع الماضي كما تعلم
، والرئيس ترامب كان في
حرب تجارية وجمركية معه ، وقال إنه
لا يوجد قدر من الحمائية الأحادية
أو
الأنانية المتطرفة قابلة للتطبيق وتعمل في
العالم اليوم ،
دعنا نذهب فقط إلى الشرق الأوسط على الرغم من
أن الحلفاء هناك أرادوا
أن يفوز الرئيس ترامب
بإسرائيل بالتأكيد أرادت حكومة رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو
أن يفوز الرئيس ترامب لأن
الرئيس ترامب قد منحه كل
ما يريده
ولم يعط إسرائيل كل شيء ولكن أعطاه
رئيس الوزراء اليميني كل ما يريده وهو
ما
تعرفه كما تعلم كان عملية السلام
ثقيلة للغاية  أه
تجاه إسرائيل لا توجد عملية سلام
مع
الفلسطينيين وبالطبع محمد بن سلمان أنت تعرف من لديه
مشاكله الاستبدادية الكبرى
، لقد أمر بقتل
صحفي وتعلم تقطيع أوصال صحفي
هو مؤيد جدًا للرئيس ترامب وهكذا
لدول الخليج  لأنهم يعتقدون
أن ذلك الرئيس ترامب كان حقاً
في صفهم ضد إيران